الاتحاد السوفيتي. يغزو اليوم
اوكرانيا ويهدد دول الغرب. لكن
وعادة ما كان يستبدلهم بحلفاء
اقوياء لا. او محايدين يخالفونه
بنظيره لكن خلفه الرئيس جو بايدن
فقد وصف بوتين بانه قاتل. بوتين
قال بوتين قبل خمسين عاما علمتني
شوارع لينينغراد قاعدة مفادها
وسيلة للدفاع هي الهجوم. بوتين
الذي ظهرت صورته المتواضعة عندما
القتالية الهجومية ايضا. وهو ما
عرف عنه انه يتخذ قاعدة. خير
الزعيم الروسي الجرأة والشجاعة
والاقدام والقوة من ممارسته
والمنغولية والارمينية
والاذربيجانية. واخيرا دخل عالم
والمصارعة الكازاخستانية
والمصارعة الاوزباكستانية
كانت تتم خلال الحقبة
السوفياتية. كما بدأت صور ستالين
الوزراء بين عامي الفين وثمانية
والفين عشر. حيث كان ممنوعا
اعاد بوتين العروض العسكرية التي
تتسم بالابهة والعظمة. كتلك التي
الجامعة. في عام الف وتسعمائة
وسبعة وتسعين. دخل بوتين
عائلة عادية. ولم يخبرني والدي
باي شيء عن نفسيهما. ولا سيما
في روسيا. لكن قبل ذلك فبوتين لم
يكن ليوجد على هذه الارض لسبب
تعرفون بمن حملت ماريا ماريا
وضعت طفلا يدعى اليوم بي
وتفصيلا. لانها مجرد تكهنات.
فليصمت ويقصد الاشخاص الذين
اعقاب الفوضى التي تلت انهيار
الشيوعية ابان تسعينيات القرن
بعيد توليه الرئاسة. عكف بوتين
على تهميش الشخصيات الليبرالية.
الطفل الذي مضى نحو الزعامة خطوة
بخطوة واعاد لروسيا امجاد
ينبض. فاسرع بها للمستشفى. وهناك
عادت للحياة مجددا. وما هي الا
العشرينيات. وتحتوي على بعض
التقنيات من فنون القتال
واربعة عشر. صحيفة امريكية تقول
ان بوتين يعاني من المراحل
الاخيرة لسرطان البنكرياس. لكن
الكريملين نفى هذه الاشاعة جملة
من عائلة امي. ووصف بالتفصيل كيف
قاتل والده بشجاعة في الحرب
السلطة منذ ذلك الحين. وان كان
قد اضطر الى شغل منصب رئيس
مقاطع مصورة له وهو يحتضن كلابه
ويساعد في رعاية نمور الامور
الرائي. عبر دونالد ترامب رئيس
امريكا السابق علنا عن اعجابه
المنصرم. وفضلا عن استعادته
الشعور بالكرامة الوطنية الذي
بموجب الدستور الروسي من تولي
فترة رئاسية ثالثة. عام الفين
يبثون هذه الاشاعات. كل شيء ما
يرام. كما قالها ناطق الكرملين.
بات سائدا في بلاده. سمح بوتين
ايضا للطبقة الوسطى بالازدهار
سياسية لنجاحه في الحفاظ على
الاستقرار النسبي لروسيا. في
سافر الشيشان على متن طائرة
النفاثة المقاتلة عام الفين.
لا يجرؤ احد على مواجهته. فهو
رجل الكرملين الاول ودب روسيا
انه اذا لم يكن من المعركة بود
فعليك ان تسدد الضربة الاولى.
التسعينيات عندما عمل كاحد كبار
مساعدي انا توليسوبتشاك عمدة
وعند حضوره مهرجانا روسيا
للدراجات على شواطئ البحر الاسود
رغم ان موسكو تظل مهيمنة على
الاقتصاد. عام الفين وخمسة عشر
رأس السنة عام الف وتسعمائة
وتسعة وتسعين تنحى الرئيس الروسي
يتسم حكم الرئيس بوتين بالقومية
الروسية المحافظة وبه اصداء قوية
وهو ما فعله الزعيم الروسي
بعملياته العسكرية في اوكرانيا.
عام الفين واحدى عشر. لكن الضوء
تسلط عليه جانب الاكثر رقة. في
لحكم القياصرة الديكتاتوري. كما
يحظى بتأييد الكنيسة الارثوذكسية
الكاراتيه. بوتين يجيد فنون
الدفاع عن لكنه يجيد الفنون
السامبو الروسية. الرياضة التي
طورها الجيش الاحمر في
بوتين يعمل جاسوسا في وكالة
الاستخبارات السوفياتية المعروفة
الروسي لانه حصل على عطلة. ولما
وصل الى حيه وجد ناقلة عسكرية
المختلفة. مثل الجودو الياباني
والملاكمة والمصارعة الحرة
سنوات وبعد انقضاء الحرب كانت
ماريا قد اصبحت حاملا. فهل
في الظهور مرة اخرى بعد ان كانت
محظورة. بوتين الرياضي. اكتسب
سانت بطرسبرج انذاك. والذي كان
قبل ذلك احد اساتذة بوتين في
المحليين الاضخم حجما والاشد منه
قوة. وهنا يقول بوتين لقد جئت من
الاتحاد السوفيتي. بدأ مسار
بوتين السياسي في اوائل
الكرملين كمدير لوكالة الامن
الفيدرالية وهي الوكالة الرئيسية
اختصارا بالكي جي بي. الصعود
السريع لنجمه في خضم فوضى انهيار
مجمع سكني بمنطقة سكنية تتسم
بالعنف في مدينة لينينغراد التي
مليئة بجثث ابناء منطقته. فاخذ
يلقي عليهم نظرة الوداع. لكن بين
والده الذي يصف بالرجل الصامت.
واضاف اعرف عن عائلة والدي اكثر
التي حلت محل الكي جي بي. وسرعان
ما عين رئيسا للوزراء في ليلة
المعرضة لخطر الانقراض. بوتين
السياسي. احرز بوتين نقاطا
العالمية الثانية. وزعم ان جده
كان يعمل طاهيا لينين وستالين.
للرياضة. فهو بطل قد حاز على
الاحزمة في الجودو. ثم انتقل الى
زوجته. فهرول مسرعا ليطمئن
عليها. لكنه وجد بيته مدمرا
ليدفنها في مكان يليق بها. وخلال
اخذه لها. وجد ان قلبها لا زال
اصبحت فيما بعد سانت بتروسبورت.
وكان يتشاجر كثيرا مع الصبية
الاب من البقاء على قيد الحياة
بعد ان امضى عدة ساعات في مستنقع
مختبئا تحت الماء. ويتنفس من
خلال قصبة بينما كان يسمع جنود
تماما. فعاد ليكتشف ان تلك الجثة
كانت لزوجته ماريا. اخذ الجثة
بينما توفي شقيقاه اللذان
يكبرانه. فيكتور والبير. كان
محملة بالجثث. علم عندها ان
العدو قصف الحي. كانت الناقلة
الالمان وهم يسيرون بجواره. ولد
بوتين في مدينة سانت بتروسبورت
السابق عن منصبه. وعين بوتين
رئيسا بالانابة. ومكث بوتين في
الروسية في عام الف تسعمائة
واثنين وخمسين. نشأ فلاديمير في
اخر. خلال احدى مهمات والده
وبسبب خيانة احد العسكريين تم
نتحدث وللقصة بقية. خلال الحرب
العالمية الثانية عاد هذا الجندي
الجثث تلك كان هناك حذاء شد
انتباه الجندي لانه اشبه بحذاء
الدب الروسي القوي والمصارع الذي
لا يهزم. ضابط المخابرات المحنك
اربعة وعشرين من رفاقه البالغ
عددهم سبعة وعشرين. تمكن بوتين
القضاء على فرقته بالكامل تقريبا
من قبل الالمان. الذين قتلوا
الذي لا يقهر.
فلاديمير بوتين احد اقوى الزعماء
في العالم وهو قيصر العصر الحديث
بشتى الطرق فقالوا ان فيه مرض
خطير. رجل الكرملين الاول الذي
ان تشتت قوتها بانهيار الاتحاد
السوفياتي. حاول الامريكان معه
تحول من شوارع الى قيصر روسيا.
عن الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين
الذي قاد بلاده من الفوضى الى ان
اصبحت اقوى دولة في العالم. رجل
المغامرات ومروض قادة العالم
القائد الذي اعاد هيبة روسيا بعد
سنوات بحسب التصنيفات. الرياضي
الشرس بطل الجودو والكاراتيه.
الطفل الذي كاد ان يدفن مع امه
وهو في احشائها. لكن القدر اراد
لهذه القصة ان لا تنتهي. الزعيم
الروسي واقوى رجل في العالم لعدة